This is parents a broken interviewing
when a parent in this more
on the 7th of april 1993
rina where and when will you go on.
I was born in italy in a small
town there in northern italy.
It is near about two hours away
from venice to be near field.
Idea of what the actual town was combat.
And. Time. What day.
What date were you born for you here
fishing for my age are your parents.
I came on the third on the 1st of 1927.
I was born on a very cold january day they
tell me because it's winter into me in
january and i was very sickly
and no one expected me limp as a matter of
fact i musta kept me downstairs to keep
me more because my mother told me and
when i was in italy my ninety
two year old aunty also told me
that she remembered when i was born
and my father came down that morning.
You know and he said if you dead
yet. And mum said no not yet.
And this is true because well i suppose
i'm sorry i think of having kids.
I will be a and how many children
that they have all together are actually
seven for my mum had i didn't survive.
Yes.
One of those was a nun actually in my she
would have been my elder silda teresa she
was a man she died a 28 mccone and
in italy in italy is you know.
So do you remember much of
easily. You know i don't.
Remember any late all you know
i don't remember any at all
and we sort of know what they
spoke about in the family.
But as far as me remembering though that.
I can remember my mother sort of saying
you know how very strict the catholic
church was you know
when you have to abide more
as one of their rules.
Rena how old were you when you
when you came when you left italy
and came out here to australia.
Well i had my four four
birthday i'm about coming out.
Do you remember the name of the day we are
all more on the side i think it was my
sister tell me that the other
day on the remember me.
Yes and we arrived in italy australia
and i don't remember anything about the
trip but i remember a street in sydney
and my brother jack had come to
me those and now im of course
and i say i asked mum i was
walking along holding mum's hand
and i had my little bag of lollies in
my hand and i think you know i offer
that man some and she
said yes. So you know.
My brother had actually left it
me when i was a two weeks old.
So he was already in australia.
Yet he left italy in 19 27
and i was born in the antilles
later my father came out in
two years again after
that we came out in 1931.
And what with the attraction for your
brother did he did he have any friends out
here. You know he knew nobody at all.
The only attraction was to get out
immediately because life was so very hard.
The reality of brothers
and sisters coming on.
So that the oldest man
or two boys really because he was barely
18. They were the ones to leave home.
There was no work there were
no where they could go.
And so they migrated and
i think in those days.
Immigration to australia was the
easiest from what i think you know.
Do you think that was hard for your
mother and father when he left the family
and travel. It wouldn't mean it
would have been hard because.
I mean just imagine my mother
in the two weeks old baby
and then one her elder son
leaving it would have been hard
but i think you could
conditioned to these things.
Another way they hadn't immediately
at the time of surviving was
probably 12 league school
and 12 they would be.
Put out to a natural place
or to a friend's place
and there they would meet
there and from board and food
and probably they were lucky to get
a change of clothes but that meant
that the family didn't have to feed
them. So that's what they need.
So instead of that a lot
didn't migrate. And.
When your father came out.
He came out follow your brother to your
brother have anything out here to attract a
father or with the intention
to bring the whole family
and now i think the intention was
to bring the whole family out.
Yes i think that's how they planned it.
My brother didn't have any bananas
or anything at the time he had
been working on dairy farm.
Mostly dairy
that used to get it on the land you
know week you know week that you.
But i believe you did stay on a dairy
farm falls out of tundra creek
or for a long while. So when
your brother came out he he.
First it was his first port of call.
Well it would have the same but
in sydney and then you came up
and you came straight to lismore.
And that's what brought your father
and the rest of the family tree as you know
you see where the thread originated he
was the original one. He was sort of. Working
very hard for him here you know once.
Yes it must have been very hard
because he didn't know the language
but having to go to australian families
in a way helped him because he learnt a
language really quickly.
So that
when we come out four years later he could
speak very well if he's still alive.
No no no he died a few years
ago. What was his name giuliani.
Do you remember any stories that he might
have told about his arrival in australia.
No no you never ever really speak
very much about it you know except
that he had to go clean carving.
Which was very hard because in those
days it was all done not only by hand
but the kind wasn't burnt
they had a load by hand.
So it was very hard and at 18 and 19
that what would have been a
very hard they work to do
that guy only for the
season he went to in india
that for a few years even after we came.
You did your father do that kind of work.
No no.
He only worked on bananas after they came
here i think they got a piece of land
and planted ananas so that when we arrived
they actually had the bananas planted.
Did your brother did he marry
you know girl i mean it.
You know we didn't he went back to italy
to get married. Yes he went back.
And did he bring his wife christine.
Yes oh yes but they came out
and they lived in the family actually with
the family which was quite acceptable in
those days you know we used to
that nibbling at what i don't
think it was a them team
and you know rina on the
out on the side how many.
Family came out on that on that trip.
My brother constantino and italian.
And my sisters even months and
then you mina and your mother
and my mother in law and stories
about the boat trip you know.
They did tell your wife about
them. My brothers and sisters or.
I can remember. Do you remember
having a birthday. Not even that.
You know when when the
boat landed read it.
Where did you land in australia in sydney.
Like i said before you know with that
child our brother. You know. And.
Do you remember your grandparents.
You know not at all. No money.
Did they ever visit you in australia.
Oh no there was no possible way
that they would they wouldn't even
if they could anyway do you know.
Do you know much about them for through
the company what they do you know me very
well. Family farmers my brother.
I mean my father by about four they were
only two boys in the family only had one
brother which was a very very small family
and most days i don't think they use
contraceptives by the way i just think it
happened that my grandmother
didn't produce anymore.
And so they were reasonably well off
sort of thing and they had the two
and my uncle only had two boys
that only agreement we will indeed lee
compared to my mother my mother was a very
good dressmaker.
And
that is how she kept the family going a
lot with my dressmaking what she would do
mostly was she would so probably
rich people of the town
and there were a few around that those
days they would be blamed owners
and they would rent their land
out to leave. So the tenants.
And she would guess we
go into their own home
and just make you machine take the kid.
Or the child but she was breastfeeding
and the others would be left with her sister
in law because the two sister in laws
lived in the same house family but
that was a very small family it wasn't
uncommon to have i've heard of 40 people in
the one house that is the grandmother
grandfather mother father
and married son with autism and
the maritimes and their children.
So that wasn't unusual but. Only
having the two. Two made it easier.
I can remember my mother saying
that one particular no it wasn't
it was one mother sister in law
had triplets and life was very hard
and of course i mean
that my husband was he wouldn't even
think of even looking at the child.
The children said i say so.
She was just at the end of the terror so
she went to the priest to ask for comfort
which is what they all did. You
know they gave him a chance.
So the priest told it to have
patience and to carry the cross lord.
Right across them and she was fed up.
So yes but our lord could have
thrown his cross down if i might win
that put me in jail.
So i think i don't think you got
the comfort they wanted to get.
I mean that's how it was you
know. Did your mother meet you.
Mother and father come
from the same village.
No actually they came from very close
but from a different really
different was it was quite close.
And it was a young women and you know. No
i don't know but they weren't very young.
No i won't you know but i suppose i
better get back on going back now
and i we're going to baghdad. I should get
back to where we were here in australia.
So there were five if you
want to buy coming out here
and you had a brother here
in australia already.
And their children left
in italy and the nun.
Yes yes yes that one had gone and
yes she she was very young i think
when she went into but i don't think
of course she never came out.
No you know and mum never saw a game and.
And you mentioned that there was another
child. There are eight children.
Yeah but when they go in very
short but two weeks old.
I think just a baby with
that after you know before.
You know i was the last one of the family.
I was on the youngest not for them.
I don't know.
Yes. When we arrived here.
We actually went into a rented house which
was a little distance behind the school
house a coffee can because you can't school
wasn't in the same place in these now
and this is where your father was living
when he you know when you were around.
Yes a coffee can.
Well actually it would be tween coffee
camp in dubai right up on top of
that we went there in this rented house
and i can remember my mother saying
that she was worried because
we had very little food and
that the children didn't have any milk.
So my brother jack is bagging blish went
and i thought like a family could we
have some milk and maybe give us some
and he offered to pay but he said i
don't worry i know how hard it is
and we having it hard to separate the dairy
farmers were really having a hard time
too. You know and it must
have been do you really.
Then the much about that period of
time when you and who are years of age
and coming to a new country.
Well i can i can remember from
there on a fair bit getting it.
I can remember.
My brother
and my father dragging all the materials
to build a house up a steep hill behind a
horse because there was no road
to where the bananas were so.
Tough and our body totally on would have
been put on the slide and dragged up
and all that you built this house
but with the help of friends.
He was a man from their home town. Yes.
He helped them build in
italy in italy for that
and tell you in time they'd met quite a few
other italians i would like would have
meditating and yes we could but try
and keep contact with the retaliation
that this man from your father's home
town city come out after your father
or oh i can't tell you i really can't say
but now i believe he would have come out
early because he was a young man too.
So that must have been good for your
father to meet someone from his own home.
Oh yes yes i'd say that
they would be yeah.
Would he have known him before he left us.
I think i probably would have from you.
Same 10 years because. The home town. Sort
of like the nella bahrain in miniature.
You know. And yes they would have
known now that grand i'd be doing.
You wouldn't you know everyone
but they didn't then you know everyone
you know everyone. Yes certainly.
Then they actually hadn't
had built a house. And.
A senate that was built. We moved them.
By this time. Describe the house again.
Describe the house.
I think this thing where all the house was
made of boards no chance of boards like
they have they were just pine boards
and which you were able
at one top of the other.
So the rain wouldn't come
in there was no lining.
And of course there's no ceiling
and we had one tank which was not attached
to the house it was we had to carry the
water. To the kitchen and into
the bathroom and everything.
I think it was because the tank
had to be lower than the house.
I imagine otherwise it wouldn't
have caught the water.
So we had to actually carry all the water
into the house for a lot of money.
And hot water column ejecting. You hand.
That's really a joke better really.
Rena with a many rooms in the house
that you lived in while it would
have three rooms one command
and one for the girls and one
for the boys and the miranda.
So there were not actually a living
room with there is no no no.
To get a kitchen and a small
room that we call the bathroom
but they didn't have anything in it or
we had was a wash tub and emus the tub
and we parted the water
and kind of the water had something more
to probably on the wouldn't stay with it
it wouldn't stay. Later on when my
brother got married he took the bedrooms
and the boys slept in the room that
was at the very end the crisis in
or it will been closed in on to start i
wouldn't have been made into a room it
wasn't my into a room and the
kitchen with the kids in the house
or was it outside when i was in the
house and to stay within the house
and with a tin type place they had
a very neat way of making me clean
fireplaces.
Well i had a tin fireplace for a long
long time even after i was married.
And there was plenty of mood of
course. So that that was no problem.
But i can remember one
day my mother telling me
that she was telling me i actually
remember i had a pain under my arm was so.
And i've never been a whinge i carry
and so i didn't say
anything for a long time
and then one day i felt something
under my arm so i write to my mother
and i said look for it
and it was a huge kick
and so she panicked say she grabbed me
and we raced over to where my
brother was in the fairway
and she showed him what i had
because she didn't know what it was
and so he just gave a laugh
and said i don't worry just pull it out me
just pull it out at me with a lot of it
was so. So bloated.
Luckily it was a model take a
look at had been a cattle sheep
that would have been really dangerous.
But i can still remember how scared
mum was and then she had me scared by
and into my time she would never
have come across anything
and i think nothing like it you know
and she didn't know what she probably
thought it was some australian surf
and something.
How did your mother cope with you know
the critters that we have in australia
and
that would have been such a different
seriously are you cited in the snakes
and i don't remember a lot about that.
I know there were some that
that is around at the time
and i can remember one time
that killed about that up
and i used to like to annoy my
brother kazoo you saw your dog me.
So i got the death and i
rangers if it happened to us
and their mother was
safe and. Do they have.
What do they have an easily
in that they do have.
But they have no snakes in a viper.
I think
and the sight of your own country may be a
lot much more than what i thought there
was a lot of insiders today.
Well they probably would have
been so it was an altogether.
You know you know not a lot of her you
know the snakes i think which would have
been but i never heard of saying.
Not about the snakes you
know all i mean with that
that as a man it would mean
to me and if he did you know.
I mean you you little say you
grew up here acclimatised
but how do you know i never heard them.
They never complain i don't
think they complain.
I think that life was so much easier here.
Life is so much easier for the poor people
in australia because they don't have
time or clothes i.
Yeah yeah i mean just imagine
what price clothes that
and i don't think any of us actually had
shoes until we came to australia we always
wore wouldn't clogs.
In my family used to make a lot of
those i still have the implements
that he made them with i don't know how i
inherited those are probably asking for
no one else and interested.
He wasn't very good at it i might add that
he even made fun here in australia. Yes.
So they all would have had
clogs with all them but my
when we arrived here we were all dressed
very neatly mother was a very proud woman
and she was a good dressmaker.
She made all your clothes.
Oh you risk your lives you know close
what kind of guys did she wear.
Well i dress a voter all
dressed in a beautiful red.
I don't know if you made it
or we were all lately dressed
when we come you know the boys.
I can say a favour of it later
and we all know except for my kids
sister emma who i'd say much.
On the way out of all this she'd never
seen she put on so much weight she looks
bloated and she was always to the right.
I can't even remember a fact
said she lost it straight away.
So she didn't fit in there is no.
So you can see it stretching on it
you know i mean photo that we took
that photo would have been taken.
Probably the day we ride or
else you know come to this.
I forgot to ask you a very important
question earlier you know what you made in a
car that was bold van something you had.
They are evolve that i am in
and where you live with their many italians
in the community the word a really lot
of italians here at the time because we
were in the second family have a family who
came to lismore the first one was bad
that they had come to years earlier.
We actually all through my life here
in the family like we have not had a
close knit italian community where sort
of been because our bananas were further
away we sort of haven't had a lot
of governing bling with italians.
Did you have did you have close
neighbors when we first went up there.
No we didn't have those neighbors later
on there wasn't another italian family
became you know what was going on and
they're interesting and have my niece
and now marry one of theirs. You know
on sunday but not very far away.
There was a row that
came out onto jinggoy.
And there was a local carrier there clarrie
garbage who used to take the bananas.
But that didn't come to light all its own
like a member there were any australians.
There were straying and what kind of food.
Did your mother call for the family.
Well i'm sure i just don't remember
the first day but my brother
and my father would have had a vegetable
garden going i'm sure some thought they
would have had some chalks and so we
would have very little meat as such
but we would have had chicken and. We
would have had the eggs and chickens.
We would have made soup out of
the old hymns i mean nothing.
Wasted and then the same
that could happen remember this is you know
they could have all the kale within my
life so much simpler for us because
the care was really a lifeline with
that inexpensive. Well probably
would have been at the time
but my brother having gone to ingham he
wouldn't they would've got a little bit of
money that way and he's coming coming.
I say that's how they paid for
the timber for the house.
And it's a moneymaker and strange.
Oh yes yes then
and there was a barter of course what they
did was put them milk in a large dish
or two depending on how
much was needed and
when the queen kind of talk you would
skim some of the cream off but not all of
that was made into butter.
Then we would make the cheese
and up and that was made.
What was left was made into a
record of cheese and then what was
that left there was spent on the pig.
So that it cow was really
very important items
and we had we have another thing
that we did have with beans.
You know call them the dried seed you
know you have the pinto beans you have a
kidney means you have so
much. You know. It's so.
I don't know what kind they were
actually i think there will be a meeting
and we plant a good time we have
pressure it is fresh vegetables
and the rest will have to
go to seed with this seed
that would last all year then
so it would be soaked overnight
and in the morning it will be cooked some
of some of the beans will be within the
salad and the rest would be mashed
up and made in the minestrone soup.
So that with the beans and the vegetables
that we grew it was really a tasty meal
and also full of biedermann
much needed by them and. Yes.
Did your mother make pasta dish attitude
like oh yes we had a spaghetti machine
which isn't like the ones i have now.
It actually turned out brown spaghetti.
My sister and her and that. Do you think.
No no i think i have made makes
me think you know she doesn't.
So she wouldn't really and we also made
our own bread and to make the bread
and i think in the beginning
they used to make it out.
When they killed a calf if you get
something like make a turn it into junket.
I should know more about that but
i think he had some time ago
but i thought it seems they want to normal
day what would you have to breakfast.
Probably great wouldn't have any
cereal probably bread which
not it would make them angry
that here they did not use.
Yeah but that wouldn't happen
but with what we had to do which
annoyed me the key was that when
that i was ready to need
having we would be family
and we used to probably only make it
every two or three days. You know.
So we had a board. Two feet square
and on that one end would be.
Two pieces of wood with about through
them and also through a long handle
and it took two people one
person would turn the dow up
and one person would go up
and down with the handle whosoever were
pushing the bag down and they handle kind.
It would needed and i that was my job
with that handle and i like that
and it would have been a hard.
It wasn't hard work but just annoyed me
and i don't know why i just hated it
but if we actually i don't know why i think
i did it was probably later on because
i wouldn't do that when
i was very young or
that we had to take home my bread to school
and i wanted to be like everybody else.
I hated that i might break. And yet
in summer. Melt with absolutely.
Before wasn't there holding them but
i really like about homemade bread.
So that's what you took to school.
Oh yes that's what we had
we used to buy the cheese
that the flour in corn bags i mean how
much they held a sugar always came in 70
pound bags. You know.
Because you have that have to be
brought up by the carrier and go on
and picked up with a slide and took
to the house the moment things.
What did you have a cigarette. If
you have a program to be salami.
But i think you know we had better i can't
actually remember you know a cereal
dream coming to a long long time and
i don't think we might have made.
I think mum made a subpar image out.
Out of.
We now call it similar enough that we
haven't different name before breakfast.
A lot. That's what they used to call it.
Yeah well she knew all about
that because it was very much like the
what they used to make polenta with any
bling. So we i think refered allotments
and you know it would have
been a lot on the mean so
that was like the spongy some
substance. Yes just a lot.
Yes yes.
And if you wanted to turn it into polenta
just made it hard for mental well also
something that was digitised coming.
You know we didn't and i
think we used to eat fresh.
You know when you make people making
the bridges making up so it takes two
or three well at least two days you know
you know i would it would stay fresh an
old. Oh yes and all year.
If we did what facilities did you
have in the house for keeping.
Well i don't remember i think the bread
box was made out of wood out of boards
that was a breed dogs must have been hard
to keep you didn't have a lot of meat
that you know well in milk and well
the milk would have. I'm fresh sea.
Every day day i'd say they would
have probably got another care after
and since they could do no good have
been praised there was no meat i can't
remember meat when we lived up on top
of gee guys going to ali they called me
and she can cook and the chicken
would have been cooked.
Yeah so that wasn't
really any problem there.
Although we had learnt from the australians
to keep the barrack room used to put an
estate agent team with or hole in the new
put it with a bag over the top of that
and convert them and then keep them
but there were no other animals.
Actually no we didn't have anything though
that what we did with the butter to make
it last was to actually turn it in what
they call now jean. We will make them see
when the strain. They don't know what to.
Moment would keep.
Did you have to apart from helping with
the great if you have to help your mother
with the chills and the
cooking. Not a lot actually.
Because i've been the youngest
one i really didn't help much.
Not at that time anyway.
If you're older brothers
and sisters have their children
to do they would have had some
but i mean the sisters of the house was
so small telegram lee wasn't a lot
but they did help in the
farm as i got older
and they had to chip grass because there
was no spraying then we didn't have any
strife at all at all had to be done by hand
and also we planned and beans and peas.
So i would have had to help there.
You know and as i did later on.
But not at that time.
When and where was the school that you
went to hell when you went out of school.
I think i would have been about six
and when i first started school.
The people that my brother knew
parmenter let me write it down below
and mccarthy camp but given the high horse
and i'll never forget it
because it had clubbed feet.
The only horse i've ever seen my lovelies.